here's somebody that very rarely makes
mistakes we're going to begin this hour
with soccer legend carly lloyd a
champion on the field and in the fight
for equality lloyd is a two-time world
cup winner two-time olympic gold
medalist and former captain of the u.s
women's national team she said goodbye
to the national team last week single
tier retiring after nearly two decades
representing this country but she's not
done playing soccer just yet glad about
that she's heading to the playoffs with
her club team gotham fc
jamie yukis looks back on some of the
greatest moments in lloyd's iconic
career
watching carly lloyd on the field is a
master class in focus and speed
[Applause]
she's one of the most legendary soccer
players to ever grace the game
the two-time world cup winner has been
on the u.s women's team for 17 years oh
it's a fantastic goal
and this year made history carly lloyd
who will be playing in her 300th game
she scores when the stakes are high
finds the back of the net
like this incredible shot from midfield
in the 2015 world cup final
leading the u.s to victory over japan
[Music]
growing up in new jersey she laced up
her cleats at five years old with a
dream to play big into the middle line
she made that dream a reality playing
for two u.s women's professional leagues
and became captain of the most
successful women's soccer team in
history this team taught all america's
children
that playing like a girl
means you're a badass lloyd took her
leadership role off the field too
joining her teammates in demanding equal
pay for women oh it's again harley
lloyd's putting out a show here she
leaves the u.s women's team as the
highest scoring midfielder in u.s
history
[Applause]
and as an inspiration for girls and
women everywhere
for cbs mornings jamie yukas new york
carly lloyd there she is joins us now
this is her first broadcast interview
since she retired from team usa welcome
welcome welcome carly lloyd soccer fans
all over the world are going no carly no
i look at that highlight tape and i said
i remember that i remember that
i remember that what does this feel like
to you
this moment and how did you know that
this moment was now
uh it's bittersweet i think it's hard
because physically i feel so good so
it's not
like i'm going out and retiring because
my body's breaking down
it's merely a life decision i've put so
many things on hold for 17 years i've
sacrificed so many things my husband's
kind of taken a back seat my friends and
family
all these years so
it's time to just live life and just
kick back and enjoy things now and i
encourage everybody to read the op-ed
that you wrote in players tribune i was
so struck by that because you said when
you look at the 17 years the word that
stands out for you is hard this was
freaking hard and the sacrifices and the
toll that it took on you
it was extremely hard and i think the
biggest reflection and i've been doing a
little bit more reflecting and
processing my career because i really
haven't processed my career i've just
wanted to have tunnel vision and focus
and just keep going keep getting better
but
it has been hard and i think people need
to know that anything you want in life
is going to be hard and
the ending and this farewell tour that
i've been on has been the most rewarding
thing i could have ever asked for and it
was because of the hard journey it's
because you appreciate those moments
those times where
you know i got up in your garage crying
yeah exactly i got up at 6 a.m and i'm
doing a run but it's all worth it in the
end and um yeah it's just been an
incredible run and i've enjoyed every
moment the arc of your career is so
interesting because most people
athletically have a great start and then
as they age they get slower they do
worse but you were the opposite you
scored most of your goals after the age
of 30. and when we were talking earlier
you just said that you actually got
better with age how do you explain that
i think it's just going about my career
doing all the right things on and off
the field from day one and never
switching off
not taking any shortcuts
doing the ice baths daily getting the
massages daily eating well hydrating
and just layering with my training you
know just constantly trying to get more
and more fit
and really just not putting limits on
myself and i think when you live a
healthy lifestyle you take care of
yourself and you don't switch off and
you just live and breathe this um
i mean there's there's no reason why i
wouldn't get better with age can i just
ask you about the psychological
component of this uh as well because you
know when you're in the public eye when
you're pro athlete you get a lot of
negative comments as you would expect
some people ignore them you opted as i
understand it to make a list of the
negative comments and save them and save
them yes
why do that i was wondering about that
too tony yeah just use it as fuel um i
you know i'm a jersey girl through and
through i i grew up just across the
bridge from philadelphia so you guys
know philly is a rough place to to be in
especially as a sports fan and
yeah i just use those to kind of
motivate me fuel me um i took note of
them and you know i remember kind of
reading this crazy article before the
2015 world cup that called me the
weirdest world-class athlete ever
took note of that and then went out and
scored a little hat trick in that final
there you go um
you know you gotta have tough skin
that's for sure but speaking of that you
know you played longer than me i played
11 years in the nfl prior to that caught
my first football at eight i know about
the long nights i know about the
injuries the physical ones but even more
so
the mental scars that we can't shake i
know about the world celebrating you
while you feel like you're in isolation
um the praise not getting to you because
the criticism is beating you down with
all of those things
would you do it all again
i would um why carly that i was
surprised why i would sacrifice
everything i would give up everything um
because when you you know you see the
the video and you see those moments and
the pictures of the trophy and
the glorious moments with my teammates
and celebrating olympic gold medals
who can say they've done that you know
it's it's a it's a very very small
opportunity that a player gets and um
i've had multiple of those opportunities
and i'm so grateful
um but this sport and my journey has
taught me so many life lessons that i
can help inspire and instill in in the
next generation and you know i'm
grateful grateful i know you're looking
forward to spending time with your
husband brian uh with family and doing
more normal things returning to the
world of mere mortals
anything in particular that you're most
excited about whether it be a place to
go in a civilian activity you know
things to eat that you were avoiding
when you were playing uh vacation is
number one i'm gonna shut off the whole
world be the first vacation where i
don't have to worry about staying fit
and running um but after that i got to
hit the slopes i haven't skied since
2005. so my husband's been brian's been
anxiously waiting uh me to get back on
the slopes how long have you been
married we have been married uh coming
up on five years right yeah that's
awesome
i'll bet he's glad yeah i think he's
more excited about the retirement than i
am
well listen enjoy your retirement you
are an absolute living legend your
legacy is not just on the field it's off
the field as well and that continues
thank you so much appreciate you joining
thank you carly lloyd you're the best